Everyone talks about getting onto training, but nobody talks about what happens next. The constant moving, the pressure to perform, supervisors who call you the trainee instead of your name. Buildings that don't work, commutes that break you teams that feel like family, and those that really don't. This episode isn't the glossy version of psychology training, but it is the real one, from a third-year trainee clinical psychologist who is living it right now and from someone who's been through it. as a qualified clinical psychologist. If you want to know what training is really like behind the scenes, then this is the conversation you want to be part of. Hope you find it useful.
每个人都在谈论如何进入培训，但没人谈论接下来会发生什么。不断的搬迁、表现的压力、那些不叫你名字只叫你“实习生”的主管。无法正常使用的建筑、让你精疲力竭的通勤、像家人一样的团队，以及那些完全不像家人的团队。这一集不是心理学培训的光鲜版本，而是真实版本，来自一位正在经历这一切的三年级临床心理学实习生，以及一位已经走过这段路、成为合格临床心理学家的过来人。如果你想了解培训幕后的真实情况，那么这就是你想要参与的对话。希望你觉得它有用。
And if you do, like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. And I'm joined by an end stage trainee clinical psychologist today, Tanya Wellmilla Gay. Hi, Tanya. Hi, Marianne. Thank you for having me. And thank you for being so willing to talk with us. So we first connected on LinkedIn and you were talking about your experiences of starting a placement and it really brought back memories. And I think it's an interesting conversation that we've not yet had on the podcast. Could you talk us through what your experiences have been like? Maybe this time around specifically starting placement, Tanya.
如果你觉得有用，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本期播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起的是一位即将结业的临床心理学实习生，坦尼娅·威尔米拉·盖伊。你好，坦尼娅。你好，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我。也谢谢你如此乐意与我们交谈。我们最初是在领英上建立联系的，当时你在谈论开始实习的经历，这真的勾起了我的回忆。我认为这是一个我们还没在播客中讨论过的有趣话题。你能给我们讲讲你的经历吗？也许可以专门谈谈这次开始实习的情况，坦尼娅。
at. Yes, so as you mentioned, I'm a later in trainee, so I'm in my final year. So it's been two years already of chopping and changing and different commutes and different teams. It's been, it's been up and up and down, I would say. Like there's been definitely positive moments where I've learned a lot about, you know, what is important to me about keeping, you know, in my routine and things that I can control, but also can be a bit of a whirlwind changing things. so much. And so that can take some time to adjust. And I guess the nature of placement is that can be up to, you know, six months. And so by the time you've, I guess, gotten used to that routine, how things have been set up, you're kind of out the door again. You've got to start
好的。正如你提到的，我是一名高年级实习生，所以我现在处于最后一年。过去两年里，我一直在不断变动，经历着不同的通勤路线和不同的团队。我想说，这起起伏伏。确实有一些积极的时刻，我学到了很多关于什么对我来说是重要的，比如保持我的日常规律，以及我可以控制的事情，但不断的变化也可能让人感到有些混乱。所以这需要一些时间来适应。我想实习的本质就是这样，可能长达六个月。所以当你刚习惯了那种规律，习惯了事情的安排方式时，你又要离开了。你必须重新开始。
almost again. And in some universities, Australia, do that six times over three years. So it's quite a lot to just, yeah, shop and change. So I'd say on the whole, kind of a mixed bag of experiences when, yeah, entering into training. Yeah, and I did do six different placements across the three years. And my experiences were different. Sometimes I was the only trainee. Sometimes I felt like there was so many trainees. There wasn't really room to stand out.
几乎是重新开始。在一些大学，澳大利亚的大学在三年内会这样做六次。所以，不断地变动确实非常多。所以总的来说，我认为进入培训时的经历是苦乐参半的。是的，我在三年里确实做了六次不同的实习。我的经历各不相同。有时我是唯一的实习生。有时我觉得实习生太多了，根本没有脱颖而出的空间。
And I just kind of blend it in. Sometimes I would come and I'd be invited to kind of, you know, pull my own cases and think about what might meet my requirements for the course or what might help me work with different clients or different presentations, what might be a trainee appropriate case. Other times I was just given like, you know, a stack of 12 files and been like, get on with this. And then, you know, it's the first placement I went to, which is interesting. It's like, review these, check, you don't know any of these people because actually if people have been working locally, that cropped up. And I was like, I'm brand new to the area. I don't
我只是随波逐流，融入其中。有时我会受邀去挑选我自己的案例，思考什么可能符合课程要求，或者什么可能有助于我与不同的客户或不同的表现形式合作，什么可能是适合实习生的案例。而其他时候，我只是被扔了一堆12份档案，然后被告知：“处理这些吧。”然后，这很有趣，是我去的第一个实习点。他们说：“审查这些，检查一下，你不认识这些人，因为实际上如果人们一直在当地工作，就会出现这种情况。”我说：“我对这个地区是全新的。我不”
think I know anyone. But even that ability to be, you know, to be seen and to be able to curate was really welcomed, whereas, yeah, you know, just getting those files, you know, slung on your desk for the trainee and to sit in the trainee's room. I very much often preferred to be called Marianne, you know what I mean? And to be seen as a person. What's your experience been like, Tanya? Yeah, I'd say also mix and there. There's so much to say. I think each question, like even just the last two questions, you could spend half an hour just talking about that. But I think teams can be so different, how they approach things can be so different if they call you the trainee or if they call
认为我认识任何人。但即使是那种被看见、能够进行筛选的能力也是非常受欢迎的，而仅仅是把那些档案扔在你的桌子上，让你坐在实习生房间里，这感觉很不一样。我通常更喜欢被叫玛丽安，你懂我的意思吗？被当作一个人来看待。坦尼娅，你的经历是怎样的？是的，我也想说那是混合的。有太多话要说了。我想每一个问题，甚至只是最后两个问题，你都可以花半小时专门讨论。但我认为团队可以非常不同，他们处理事情的方式可以非常不同，取决于他们是叫你“实习生”还是叫
you by your name. I remember in my first place, and they kept calling me the assistant psychologist. And I think that irked me a little bit because I felt like I was, you know, I've gone into training now so I feel like almost like I've worked so hard to get to this place so I kind of want to be acknowledged as being in that position some teams are very boundaries which I struggle with because I like being like so what did you do on the weekend and you know what how are your kids and so like I like having those informal conversations because it feels safer in the team so then you know if you're struggling that you know you can go to your team and there are the teams that that feel like they're almost like many families because I think when you're working so intimately
你的名字。我记得在我的第一个实习点，他们一直叫我“心理学助理”。我觉得这让我有点恼火，因为我觉得我已经进入了培训阶段，所以我感觉自己为了走到这一步付出了很多努力，所以我希望我的职位得到认可。有些团队非常有界限感，这让我很挣扎，因为我喜欢那种“你周末做了什么？”或者“你的孩子怎么样？”之类的交流。我喜欢进行那些非正式的谈话，因为这让团队感觉更安全。这样你就知道，如果你遇到困难，你可以去找你的团队。还有那些感觉几乎像小家庭一样的团队，因为我认为当你如此亲密地工作时
and with people who are vulnerable and struggling, you do create those bonds with your team. And if you can rely on your team and I found that in a lot of placements, you can do really, really good work because you feel safe enough. So yeah, I'd say quite varied in terms of, yeah, how teams can kind of interact with trainees. Yeah, and it is that team culture, isn't it? It's trying to work out, you know, where you go for lunch,
与那些脆弱且挣扎的人一起工作，你确实会与你的团队建立起纽带。如果你能依靠你的团队，我在很多实习中发现，你可以做出非常非常好的工作，因为你感到足够安全。所以，是的，我想说在团队如何与实习生互动方面，经历是非常多样的。是的，这就是团队文化，不是吗？试图弄清楚午餐去哪里吃，
whether you all eat together, you know, what the deal is. I am always a person first, so I do really like the chance to connect, you know, a bit more informally over lunch. And I remember one of my placements, one of my supervisors or one of the team members, had a litter of labradoodle puppies. And so a lot of the time was sort of spent looking at photos and videos of them. And that was really, really nice. that was like a non-psychology topic that we could kind of all just kind of, you know, spend some time, you know, just connecting and being, being ourselves and being human. And in that placement, I was very kind of newly in love as well.
大家是否一起吃饭，情况如何。我总是先把自己当作一个人，所以我真的很喜欢在午餐时进行更非正式的交流。我记得在我的一个实习点，我的一位主管或团队成员有一窝拉布拉多犬。所以很多时间都花在看它们的照片和视频上。这真的非常好。那是一个非心理学的话题，我们可以聚在一起，花点时间，只是建立联系，做回我们自己，做回人类。在那个实习期间，我也刚坠入爱河。
So I think back very fondly to that time. I can hear my husband now in the kitchen. He's on annual leave this week. And it's like, you know, it's still the same guy that I was on placement three, you know, talking to my team about and who I'd met on like, you know, I think it was a second week of the second year of training. And yeah, I just think like very fondly to that time and to what I learned, you know, from that team about the way of, you know, just about their ways of being. And I think it's often, yes, teams are often so defined by the spaces they work in as well. So that was a not
所以我非常深情地回忆那段时光。我现在能听到我丈夫在厨房里的声音。他这周在休年假。他还是我在第三个实习点时，和我的团队谈论的那个家伙，也是我在第二年第二周左右遇到的那个人。是的，我非常深情地回忆那段时光，以及我从那个团队身上学到的关于他们处事方式的东西。而且我认为，团队往往也受到他们工作空间的定义。所以那是一个
fit for purpose building that we were in, but you kind of made the most of the rickety stairs and the tiny little kitchen with the tap that did or didn't work, you know what I mean? And then whether you could or couldn't get in the door because it was open or locked that day and whether the lock works. And then my experience of being in other buildings where they were kind of modern buildings, where there was space to come together. And, you know, we're all just trying to make the best of the situation we find ourselves in. But sometimes I think the spaces, they do make a big difference, don't they? Yeah, totally. That made me think of two placements I've had that are so contrastingly different in terms of the environment and then also kind of like what the wider team
不适合办公的建筑，但你还是充分利用了摇摇欲坠的楼梯和那个水龙头时好时坏的小厨房，你懂我的意思吗？还有那天门是开着还是锁着，锁能不能用。然后我也有在其他建筑工作的经历，那是些现代建筑，有聚在一起的空间。我们都在努力适应我们所处的环境。但有时我认为空间确实会产生很大的影响，不是吗？是的，完全同意。这让我想起了我有过的两个实习点，它们在环境方面形成了鲜明的对比，还有更广泛的团队
thinks of psychology and the funding and things like that. So I was in quite, I guess, well-known renowned, pediatric hospital, and a lot of money, a lot of funding. And so a lot of what's nice, opportunities and spaces and the ability to kind of network and there's conferences and a lot of that going on, which is really lovely. And then compared to my current placement, which is also in another hospital, but in a systemic team where we're all in this box room, there's like six of us in this box room. And we're sharing tables and sharing spaces and having to like kind of do a bit of musical chairs trying to get in and out of the room. So it's, yeah, it is really amazing how Yeah, services or teams and then how teams operate.
对心理学、资金等方面的看法。我曾在一家非常知名、著名的儿科医院工作，那里资金充足。所以有很多很好的机会、空间，以及建立人脉的能力，还有会议等等，这真的很棒。相比之下，我目前的实习点也在另一家医院，但在一个系统性团队中，我们都挤在这个小隔间里，六个人挤在一个小房间里。我们共用桌子，共用空间，为了进出房间不得不玩“抢椅子”游戏。所以，是的，服务或团队以及团队的运作方式确实令人惊叹。
And then it makes me think, well, how is systemic family therapy seen in services? Like, is it valued? If it was valued more, would they be in a different space where people could kind of walk around without playing musical chairs? So, yeah, very, I guess, different across placements and funding and opportunities. And I guess as trainees, you're just trying to make the most of what's there, if that's, you know, just trying to have, you know, with a systemics team that is, I get unaware or finds it difficult to kind of support itself. I think in clinical psychology, we have a lot of backing sometimes about how we have service development and outcome measures, and that's a little bit more difficult
这让我思考，系统家庭治疗在服务中是如何被看待的？它受到重视吗？如果它更受重视，他们是否会处于一个人们可以走动而不用玩“抢椅子”游戏的空间里？所以，是的，在实习点、资金和机会方面确实非常不同。我想作为实习生，你只是在努力充分利用现有的资源，如果那是……只是试图……对于一个可能不了解或发现很难支持自己的系统性团队来说。我认为在临床心理学中，我们有时在服务发展和结果衡量方面有很多支持，而在
in systemic. So I think I've been trying to take that role on in the current placement, just to see, like, what can I do as a trainee with my knowledge about clinical psychology and how can I input it there. So I think we do try to make the best of the situation that we're in as trainees as well. Yeah. Yeah, it is tricky though, isn't it? Because you are very much trying to make sure that the clients have a good service and that you are, I don't know, a useful part of the team and that you're also managing your own learning objectives because I certainly speak from my own experience here that I needed to be able to get a certain amount of kind of clinical cases or, you know, days on placement, sessions even that I'd done, you know,
系统性治疗中这稍微困难一些。所以我一直在尝试在当前的实习中承担那个角色，看看作为一名拥有临床心理学知识的实习生，我能做些什么，以及我如何能在那儿做出贡献。所以我认为作为实习生，我们确实在努力充分利用我们所处的环境。是的。是的，这确实很棘手，不是吗？因为你非常努力地确保客户得到良好的服务，确保你是一个有用的团队成员，同时还要管理你自己的学习目标。我当然是从我自己的经验出发，我需要能够获得一定数量的临床案例，或者实习天数，甚至是我完成的会话，
perhaps ticking off different, you know, methods of working with people. So either one-to-one or group work, systemic, you know, working with kind of wider systems. And so you're kind of trying to think, oh, how can I do this? How can I do that? Whilst also being under, you know, the microscope of your supervisor, maybe even if there's a manager on placement, thinking about whether you might be compared to previous or part, or current trainees, but also meeting the standards expected by your university and any placement
也许要勾选不同的与人合作的方法。所以无论是一对一还是小组工作、系统性工作，与更广泛的系统合作。所以你一直在想，哦，我该怎么做这个？我该怎么做那个？同时还要在主管的显微镜下，甚至如果实习点有经理的话，还要考虑你是否会被拿来与以前的、现在的实习生进行比较，同时还要达到大学和任何实习
supervisor. And it's, it can be a lot to juggle, can't it, Tanya? Yes, totally. It can feel like a lot of pressure. Something that came to mind when you were speaking is this idea of like wanting to be like led and guided by your interests and to stay authentic as like a kind of psychologist that you want to be in your clinical work, but also there's this like big elephant in the room, but you need to take off X, Y, Z competency. So you need to prioritize me first, and then we can think about what you're interested in. So yeah, there's definitely been moments where I've had to say no to something and then pick up, pick up something else, which is more fitting to what I need to kind of tick off, which is unfortunate, but also part of the kind of expectation of training is that we are here
主管所期望的标准。这确实有很多事情要兼顾，不是吗，坦尼娅？是的，完全是。这可能会让人感到压力很大。你说话时我想到的一点是，这种想要被自己的兴趣所引导，并作为你想成为的那种心理学家在临床工作中保持真实的想法，但同时房间里还有一只“大象”，你需要勾选X、Y、Z能力。所以你需要先优先考虑这些，然后我们才能考虑你感兴趣的事情。所以，是的，确实有几次我不得不拒绝某件事，然后选择另一件事，这更符合我需要勾选的要求，这很不幸，但也是培训期望的一部分，即我们在这里
to meet these competencies as well. And I think under the scrutiny of your supervisor, like you said, can be really hard because, yeah, I mean, we don't get to choose our supervisors. We don't get to really choose our placements so much. Like they get randomly allocated to us based on what we need for our competencies. So it's, we're working with people. Maybe sometimes we wouldn't have ordinarily worked with or would have preferred to work with. And so that means, yeah, a lot of pressure and sometimes anxiety.
也要达到这些能力要求。而且我认为在主管的审视下，就像你说的，可能真的很难，因为，是的，我们无法选择我们的主管。我们无法真正选择我们的实习点。它们是根据我们需要的能力随机分配给我们的。所以，我们在与人合作。有时可能是我们通常不会合作或更愿意合作的人。这意味着，是的，压力很大，有时会感到焦虑。
to get it right. I mean, supervisors, they do ultimately rate you and they pass you on your placement if they think that's appropriate. And so there does feel like there is, yeah, you are constantly kind of being tested. And sometimes that can feel safe, like I was saying before. And it's okay to make mistakes. So it's okay to kind of ask questions. Whereas maybe for some supervisors, it feels like it's quite critical. And I think that can be a little bit harmful sometimes. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, you make a really good point in that you're not necessarily choosing these placements. You're not choosing the location. And for me, that's tricky. So I was at the Coventry and Warwickshire University courses and they had a very big patch that extended out even to kind of Worcestershire and Herefordshire. And then obviously kind of to Birmingham, like the edges of Birmingham, because obviously there's a Birmingham course as well. Coventry, kind of rural Warwickshire, it was big. And so, you know, potentially you could have been sent anywhere.
为了做好。我的意思是，主管最终确实会给你评分，如果他们认为合适，他们会让你通过实习。所以确实感觉你一直在被测试。有时这会让人感到安全，就像我之前说的。犯错是可以的。问问题是可以的。而对于某些主管来说，这感觉相当严厉。我认为这有时可能是有害的。是的，绝对是。而且，你提出了一个很好的观点，即你不一定能选择这些实习点。你不能选择地点。对我来说，这很棘手。我在考文垂和沃里克郡大学的课程，他们有一个很大的覆盖区域，甚至延伸到伍斯特郡和赫里福德郡。然后显然还有伯明翰，伯明翰边缘，因为显然也有伯明翰的课程。考文垂，某种乡村沃里克郡，它很大。所以，你有可能被派往任何地方。
But of course, you're not necessarily moving house every placement. You probably are going to be staying within the same location. So I moved, for the course, I moved to Coventry. And I don't think they saw my Post-it note that said, I'm moving to Coventry because they allocated me a base closest to where I used to live, which was like, you know, 40 miles away. So they were trying to be helpful, but actually shot me in the foot. But actually, yes, when it came to placement, I moved for, so I moved for the course,
但当然，你并不一定每次实习都要搬家。你可能还是会留在同一个地方。所以我搬了，为了课程，我搬到了考文垂。我不认为他们看到了我的便利贴，上面写着“我搬到了考文垂”，因为他们给我分配了一个离我以前住的地方最近的基地，那大概有40英里远。所以他们试图提供帮助，但实际上却帮了倒忙。但实际上，是的，当谈到实习时，我搬了，所以我为了课程搬了，
and then I moved at the start of my second year as well. So just before I met, just before I met the guy that was my husband, my husband. And yeah, I was then using those. And then I moved again. I moved again. I moved. I bought a house. So I moved three times.
然后我在第二年开始时也搬了。所以就在我遇到我丈夫之前，就在我遇到我丈夫之前。是的，我当时就在用那些基地。然后我又搬了。我又搬了。我搬了。我买了一套房子。所以我搬了三次。
And so you're then using those bases to get, to your placements. But I think this is probably more of an issue in London as well, is that you might be then having very long commutes. You might be having to get up really early. You might be finishing late. You might be stuck on a tube, you know. And if an MDT meeting runs over,
所以你当时就在用那些基地去你的实习点。但我认为这在伦敦可能也是一个更大的问题，你可能会有很长的通勤时间。你可能不得不很早起床。你可能很晚才下班。你可能被困在地铁里。如果多学科团队会议超时了，
or if you've got to fill in a safeguarding referral before you finish, it knocks into your time that you can't necessarily get back. So some teams allow you to, to do flexi working, some do not. And yeah, then how you have your life. So I know when we had a chat on the phone before we met and it's like, how do I make sure I fit in my yoga class?
或者如果你在下班前必须填写一份保障转介表，它会占用你无法找回的时间。所以有些团队允许你弹性工作，有些则不允许。然后你如何安排你的生活。所以我知道在我们见面之前我们在电话里聊过，就像，我如何确保我能参加我的瑜伽课？
How do I make sure I'm seeing my friends? Maybe my trainee friends, but maybe non-psychology friends as well. How do I do all of this? What's your experience been like in that area, Tanya? Yeah. So in this placement, I think I've been brave enough to ask about flexi leave, or just sorry, not flexily, flexi working. Because I've identified that physical activity doing yoga classes, going to the gym is important
我如何确保我能见到我的朋友？也许是我的实习生朋友，但也可能是非心理学的朋友。我该如何做这一切？坦尼娅，你在那方面的经历是怎样的？是的。所以在这个实习点，我想我已经足够勇敢去询问弹性休假，或者抱歉，不是弹性休假，是弹性工作。因为我已经确定了身体活动、参加瑜伽课、去健身房对我来说很重要。
to me. I think that sets me up really well for the rest of my day. And also makes me feel like I've carved out that time for myself, even if I don't get it in the evening. Because like you said, safeguarding referrals, overrunning MDT meetings. I can't anticipate if that will happen or not. but it might. And so this is me kind of protecting time for myself and that kind of non-negotiable for me. But that is after two years of training. And so I think if I guess trainees feel like
我认为这让我为接下来的一天做好了充分的准备。也让我觉得我为自己留出了那段时间，即使我在晚上没有得到它。因为就像你说的，保障转介、超时的多学科团队会议。我无法预料这是否会发生。但它可能会。所以这是我在为自己保护时间，这对我来说是不可妥协的。但那是在两年的培训之后。所以我认为如果实习生觉得
they need that time, I would definitely sort of protect that. But I think along the way I've found different things that work for me. Like I have a niece who's 18 months old. And I think that being with her really rejuvenates me and I think I found that to be really important so even though they live about an hour and a half away even though it takes an hour and a half to get to them I'll still kind of make that time because I know that that helps me that's soothing for me seeing friends as well and you kind of mention maybe non-psychology friends it's funny I think I see psychology friends all the time I think most friends now are psychology friends because they just get it I don't know if you found out when you were training that no one else quite gets it like your fellow training friends.
他们需要那段时间，我绝对会保护它。但我认为在这一过程中，我找到了适合我的不同方法。比如我有一个18个月大的侄女。我认为和她在一起真的让我恢复了活力，我觉得这非常重要，所以即使他们住在一个半小时车程外，即使花一个半小时才能见到他们，我还是会抽出时间，因为我知道这对我很有帮助，这对我来说很舒缓。见朋友也是，你提到了非心理学的朋友，很有趣，我想我一直在见心理学朋友，我想大多数朋友现在都是心理学朋友，因为他们就是懂。我不知道你在培训时是否发现，没有其他人像你的实习生朋友那样真正理解。
It doesn't matter how much you describe it. They'll be non-psychology friends. They just really get it without even you having to say anything. They're like, it's okay, I understand. We're in the thick of it now. So, yeah, I'd say still carving out time to see them has been really lovely and family. And for me, actually, I do enjoy travelling. So I think as much as possible with the annual leave that we have, I've tried to go on like short city breaks.
无论你描述得多么详细。他们会是非心理学的朋友。他们只是真正理解，甚至不需要你说任何话。他们会说：“没关系，我理解。我们现在正处于水深火热之中。”所以，是的，我想说抽出时间去见他们一直很美好，还有家人。对我来说，实际上，我确实喜欢旅行。所以我认为在我们的年假允许的情况下，我尽可能尝试去进行短途城市度假。
I think that kind of shift in perspective and shift in routine again, but in a way that feels more in control. And just being by the sea or, you know, going on a hike, I think these are all kind of things that are meaningful to me. And I think you do get that from changing so much in placement. So if there is anything kind of positive to gain from that, I think it is figuring out what you. you think is non-negotiable for your kind of own well-being. Yeah, absolutely. There's a whole episode coming out. I think it will have come out just before this episode,
我认为那种视角的转变和日常生活的再次转变，但以一种感觉更可控的方式。只是待在海边，或者去徒步旅行，我认为这些都是对我来说有意义的事情。而且我认为你确实能从实习中的频繁变动中得到这些。所以如果有什么积极的东西可以从中获得，我想就是弄清楚你认为对你自己的幸福不可妥协的事情。是的，绝对是。有一整集节目即将播出。我想它会在这一集之前播出，
probably in a couple of episodes before this one, where we're looking at travel in psychology, both kind of before training and kind of after training as well and how that can kind of help people. Maybe it's not a kind of a choice between travel and psychology, like that you could do both. So that might be one to check out if people find that an interesting idea.
可能在这一集之前的几集里，我们正在探讨心理学中的旅行，包括培训前和培训后，以及它如何能帮助人们。也许这不是在旅行和心理学之间做选择，而是你可以两者兼顾。所以如果人们觉得这是一个有趣的想法，那可能值得一看。
Yeah, I mean, I think the thing that I'm most thankful for, not most thankful, but very thankful for about being a psychologist is the people I've met along the way who are now my very dear friends. And yeah, it's surprising. Some of them have been, you know, supervisors or have been on my team.
是的，我的意思是，我认为作为一名心理学家，我最感激的，不是最感激，但非常感激的是我在这一路上遇到的人，他们现在是我非常亲爱的朋友。而且，是的，这很令人惊讶。他们中的一些人曾经是主管，或者曾经在我的团队里。
Some of them have been fellow trainees or just people I've met along the way. And being able to, you know, have those people at the end of our phone for support, but also, I don't know, compassion and validation is incredible. It's one of my favorite things about the career. And also, you know, I have got non-psychology friends. And they obviously think, you know, that you're amazing because all of your friends should think you're great, right?
他们中的一些人是实习生同伴，或者只是我在路上遇到的人。能够拥有那些人在电话那头提供支持，而且，我不知道，同情和认可，真是太棒了。这是我最喜欢的职业特点之一。而且，你知道，我也有非心理学的朋友。他们显然认为你很了不起，因为你所有的朋友都应该认为你很棒，对吧？
But there's nothing quite as validating as getting, you know, well done. When you, when you announced that you were going to be a trainee, I think the validations from the people that actually know what that involves, because there's certain people in your life that always thought you would do it and that you'd get it and you, you know, you'll just carry on trying and then you'll get it, you know, because you're all really good, you're brilliant. And of course, that's lovely. We all need people like that in our life. But actually the people that really have that informed idea of what this really is when they say, well done and you really deserve this. For me, that means a little bit more. Yeah, definitely. And I think
但没有什么比得到“做得好”的认可更让人欣慰的了。当你宣布你要成为一名实习生时，我认为来自那些真正知道这意味着什么的人的认可，因为你生命中总有一些人认为你会做到，你会得到它，你会继续努力，然后你会得到它，因为你们都很优秀，你们很棒。当然，那很美好。我们生活中都需要那样的人。但实际上，那些真正了解这到底是什么的人，当他们说“做得好，你真的应得的”时，对我来说，那意味着更多。是的，绝对是。而且我认为
you do celebrate those wins with your trainees, I think, like, because we have to do assignments alongside placement. And we've also got to, I guess, submit a really heavy thesis. So there are moments where, I guess, you are there for each other and you're kind of celebrating. And, I mean, I hosted a get-together over the weekend. And half the room were pretty much all psychologists. But I really, yeah, I really love that because I feel like we are all kind of connecting. And I know maybe when we finish, we'll all kind of go off in kind of different trajectories, but we'll have really bonded through these last, I guess, three years.
你确实会和你的实习生同伴一起庆祝这些胜利，因为我们必须在实习的同时完成作业。我们还必须提交一份非常沉重的论文。所以有些时刻，我想，你们在那里互相支持，你们在庆祝。而且，我的意思是，我周末举办了一个聚会。房间里有一半人几乎都是心理学家。但我真的，是的，我真的很喜欢那样，因为我觉得我们都在建立联系。我知道也许当我们结业时，我们都会走上不同的轨道，但我们会在过去这三年里建立起深厚的感情。
So yeah. And going to people's weddings and people having babies. So like people are going through like their own life transitions during the course. and I think it's really nice to see that a friend went on Mat leave and she posted in our trainee group chat like her baby daughter and like everyone is celebrating them and super happy and a lot of people have gotten married on the course and we'll be getting married once the course is finished so yeah it's nice that we've created those bonds yeah like life happens whilst you're being a trainee and you know people will often say oh I want to get on before I'm 27 so that I qualify before I'm 30 and, you know, I want to think about getting qualified before I have children or I want to get married before the course. And I'd say, yeah, it does constrain your time because you have to have deadlines to, you know, to submit your different academic work. You will need to think about how many days you have on placement. But it is entirely possible to get married, to move house, to buy a
所以，是的。还有去参加人们的婚礼，人们生孩子。所以人们在课程期间经历着他们自己的人生转变。而且我认为看到一个朋友休产假，她在我们的实习生群聊里发了她女儿的照片，每个人都在为他们庆祝，超级开心，而且很多人在课程期间结婚了，我们会在课程结束后结婚，所以，是的，很高兴我们建立了那些纽带。是的，就像当你是一名实习生时，生活仍在继续，人们经常会说：“哦，我想在27岁之前进入这个行业，这样我就能在30岁之前获得资格。”而且，你知道，我想在生孩子之前获得资格，或者我想在课程结束前结婚。我会说，是的，它确实限制了你的时间，因为你必须有截止日期来提交你不同的学术工作。你需要考虑你在实习期间有多少天。但结婚、搬家、买房、
property to have children on the course. You've got to live your life. You've got to put yourself first and know that this is a fixed term contract and it can be extended to be able to, you know, if you've been unwell or if you have extenuating circumstances or if you have maternity or paternity leave, you can, yeah, this is your life. You get to do it in a way that kind of, yeah, authentic to you, try to reduce the shoulds, I think. Yeah, yeah, totally. I agree. And I think I've heard that a lot whilst on the course. I say Royal Holloway, so my university are quite good at that. I think they are very open and understanding and they kind of acknowledge that people do have their own lives and things do happen maybe unexpectedly. And so, yeah, I think they are
在课程期间生孩子是完全可能的。你必须过你的生活。你必须把自己放在第一位，并知道这是一个定期合同，如果由于你身体不适、有特殊情况，或者你有产假或陪产假，它可以延长。这是你的生活。你可以以一种对你来说真实的方式去做，我认为尽量减少那些“应该”。是的，是的，完全同意。我同意。而且我想我在课程期间经常听到这个。我说的是皇家霍洛威学院，所以我的大学在这方面做得很好。我认为他们非常开放和理解，他们承认人们确实有自己的生活，事情确实可能出乎意料地发生。所以，是的，我认为他们
quite good at kind of hearing you as, you know, as person, seeing you as a person. So I think that's been quite a helpful as a part of the training process to have a good, like, staff team, good course that are quite supportive and help you in that way. And I'm a course representative for my co-co- and I've been the course representative for the last three years. So I take the feedback to and from the course and the kind of trainees. And it's really interesting. being in those rooms with the course staff and the directors and stuff and but then also hearing from the trainees and i think raw hollaway they do a good job of taking on that that feedback and it does it sounds like it is important to them they want to honor that and yeah that sounds like a really
在把你当作一个人来看待方面做得相当好。所以作为培训过程的一部分，有一个好的员工团队、好的课程，他们非常支持并以那种方式帮助你，这非常有帮助。我是我们课程的代表，过去三年我一直是课程代表。所以我把反馈带给课程和实习生，也带回给他们。这真的很有趣。在那些房间里和课程工作人员、主管们在一起，但同时也听取实习生的意见。我认为皇家霍洛威学院在接受反馈方面做得很好，听起来这确实对他们很重要，他们想尊重这一点。而且，是的，这听起来是一个非常
good example of practicing leadership as well and that can be something that feels harder to carve out as a trainee, but I think it's really important because when you qualify, you might find that you are the leader. And suddenly you're like, oh, I feel woefully and equipped, you know, you might, you might be, you know, one of the most senior people. You might be the most senior psychologist on your team. You might have an assistant, you might have a trainee, you might not, it might just be you and yeah like any opportunity to practice leadership and to try to reduce that imposter syndrome a little bit I think is time well spent yeah yeah for sure and I think we learned a lot of skills in training and I think to be able to kind of demonstrate some of them like leadership
好的练习领导力的例子，这可能是作为实习生感觉更难争取到的东西，但我认为这非常重要，因为当你获得资格时，你可能会发现你就是领导者。突然间你会觉得，哦，我感到非常缺乏准备，你可能会是团队中最资深的人之一。你可能是团队中最资深的心理学家。你可能有一名助理，你可能有一名实习生，你可能没有，可能只有你一个人。而且，是的，任何练习领导力并试图稍微减少那种冒名顶替综合症的机会，我认为都是值得花时间的。是的，是的，当然。而且我认为我们在培训中学到了很多技能，我认为能够在进入世界之前，在一种安全、受控的环境中展示其中一些技能，比如领导力，
in a kind of safe kind of controlled environment before heading off into the world and kind of being in situations where you are the most senior person in the team is really helpful just to kind of get a sense of it. In our university, we do an annual conference. And so that's an opportunity for trainings to kind of get involved in leadership or you can kind of ask in placement if you can supervise an assistant under the supervision of your supervisor. Or something I'm trying to do in my current service is do a reflective practice for trainees or I can, me in another third year trainee facility. take that. So I think these are all really helpful skills to kind of cultivate during the training rather than, you know, you're just been thrown into it and it's very, yeah, anxiety provoking. So yeah, it's a good opportunity whilst training. Absolutely. And I'm aware that
然后在你成为团队中最资深的人的情况下，这真的很有帮助，只是为了获得一种感觉。在我们的大学，我们举办年度会议。所以这是一个实习生参与领导力的机会，或者你可以在实习中询问是否可以在主管的监督下监督一名助理。或者我目前的服务中正在尝试做的一件事是为实习生进行反思性实践，或者我可以，我和另一位三年级实习生一起主持。所以，我认为这些都是在培训期间培养的非常有用的技能，而不是你只是被扔进去，这非常令人焦虑。所以，是的，这是培训期间的一个好机会。绝对是。而且我知道
your cohort was, is significantly larger than mine. So when I qualified, when I trained, there was 15 of us that started and then by the time we finished there was one person that joined us from the year above because she'd had a baby. So there was 16 of us when we finished and it meant that we could hang out together and often did. So during lunch times and break times we'd all smooched together on this lovely big sofa area and yeah got to actually I feel like I had a relationship with all of all of my fellow cohort. obviously some of my relationships were closer than others, but sometimes we did all go out together as well, probably less as time went on. And I know that as being part of a bigger cohort,
你们的班级比我的大得多。所以当我获得资格时，当我接受培训时，我们有15个人开始，然后到我们结束时，有一个人从高一年级加入了我们，因为她生了一个孩子。所以我们结束时有16个人，这意味着我们可以聚在一起，而且经常这样做。所以在午餐时间和休息时间，我们都会挤在这个可爱的大沙发区，是的，我确实觉得我和我所有的同伴都有联系。显然我的一些关系比其他人更亲密，但有时我们也会一起出去，随着时间的推移可能少了。而且我知道作为大班级的一部分，
I think you said that you're into the 40s, that is a very different, a very different beast entirely, isn't it? Yeah, yeah, definitely. So yeah, we are about 56 at the moment. So there's, yeah, quite a lot of us. And it's nice because I feel like our cohort do get on and we do kind of get stuck into lectures and we can all kind of have conversations of group discussions. It's been, yeah, I guess with more people, you have kind of more voices, more kind of more conversations, which can be kind of a bit of a mixed bag. But then naturally, I guess groups do form and you find people who are more kind of aligned with you. And that means that maybe those friendships can flourish a little bit more. But also we have spaces that we spoke before about this, about how
我想你说你们有40多人，那完全是另一回事，不是吗？是的，是的，绝对是。所以，是的，我们现在大约有56人。所以，是的，我们有很多。而且这很好，因为我觉得我们的班级相处得很好，我们确实会投入到讲座中，我们都可以进行小组讨论。这，是的，我想人多了，你有更多的声音，更多的对话，这可能有点苦乐参半。但自然地，我想小组确实会形成，你会找到与你更志同道合的人。这意味着也许那些友谊可以更繁荣一点。但我们也有空间，我们之前谈过这个，关于大学如何
universities can kind of facilitate things like reflective practice, where these are maybe in smaller groups, where it feels a bit more safer to be a bit more funnel board share, kind of how you're really doing around juggling everything, the placement, research, academic assignments. And so that is really nice where we can kind of in a more kind of intimate way, discuss how we're doing with people so it's nice that the university can facilitate that but yeah it's quite it's quite a lot and can be quite daunting you know you're in front of 50 60 people and i think we're at a place where we feel around each other to voice how we feel or like say answers and lectures and give our opinions but yeah it's it's taken some time obviously to get to that point in such a large group so
促进反思性实践之类的事情，这些可能是在较小的小组中，在那里感觉更安全，可以分享更多关于你如何真正应对这一切，实习、研究、学术作业。所以这真的很好，我们可以以一种更亲密的方式讨论我们的情况，所以大学能促进这一点真是太好了。但，是的，这确实很多，而且可能相当令人生畏。你面对着50、60个人，我想我们处于一个我们可以互相表达感受，或者在讲座中说出答案并发表意见的地方。但，是的，在这样一个大群体中达到这一点显然花了一些时间。
i think by our year our final year now it's been a bit more easier to be in those bigger groups I think. Yeah, that is quite a lot of different dynamics to take into account, you know, 56 people. That is a lot. And even the ability to be able to get to know someone and hold in mind what their strengths are, what their story is, what their background is, you know, to be able to feel like you know that person and can, you know, just interact with them as you would. And, you know, another close colleague, like 56 people, that is a lot.
所以我认为到我们现在最后一年，在那些大群体中感觉稍微容易了一些。是的，要考虑的动态确实很多，56个人。那真的很多。甚至能够去了解某人，并记住他们的优势是什么，他们的故事是什么，他们的背景是什么，你知道，能够感觉你了解那个人，并且可以，你知道，像你对待其他亲密同事那样与他们互动，56个人，那真的很多。
And, you know, interpersonally, there will be differences there. Of course there are. And, you know, some courses, I know counselling psychology say that it's mandatory to have therapy. And on my course, we had personal development groups that ran for the first 18 months. But there was no one-to-one therapy as a mandatory component. I did undertake that in my final year and I found it really, really helpful. But I think for our own insight and our own reflection, our own ability to know what therapy is like and to have all of those, oh, what does my therapist think of me? And, you know, oh, I'll save that for therapy. It is really helpful, I think, to have therapy. Is that, is that in courses today, are they strongly suggesting that? Is it available at reduced rates? Other clinicians that may be offered that free locally. How has, how's that been for you? Yeah, it's a really good point. I think, like you said, there are courses where it's mandatory and sort of that's offered and you have to kind of, evidence that as well. So there were a whole process around receiving that kind of support. I think it's been difficult. I think like having therapy alongside my training would have been
而且，在人际交往方面，会有差异。当然会有。而且，你知道，有些课程，我知道咨询心理学说强制要求接受治疗。在我的课程中，我们有前18个月运行的个人发展小组。但没有作为强制性组成部分的一对一治疗。我在最后一年确实进行了治疗，我发现它真的非常有帮助。但我认为为了我们自己的洞察力和反思，我们自己了解治疗是什么样的能力，并拥有所有那些“哦，我的治疗师怎么看我？”以及“哦，我会把那个留到治疗中说。”我认为拥有治疗真的很有帮助。这是，这是当今课程中的一部分吗？他们强烈建议吗？它有折扣价吗？其他临床医生可能会在当地免费提供。那对你来说怎么样？是的，这是一个很好的观点。我想，就像你说的，有些课程是强制性的，那种支持是提供的，你也必须证明这一点。所以围绕接受那种支持有一个完整的过程。我认为这很困难。我想在培训的同时进行治疗会是
something that I would have really benefited from. And I think there's, there's more to it. I guess that you have to kind of check its affordability and like you said, if there's in kind of low cost options for trainings, which I've seen around. But I think I remember in my first year, I contacted a few private psychologists and I think I was placed on a wait list but I think I probably could have been more proactive to kind of check on that wait list but I hadn't been contacted and it's been two years now so it's thinking about like if it is a priority for you kind of making sure that as much as the other things we said were non-negotiable like seeing family and you know and being active and catching up with friends is therapy kind of non-negotiable for you do you
我确实会从中受益匪浅的事情。而且我认为，还有更多。我想你必须检查它的负担能力，就像你说的，如果实习生有低成本的选择，我在周围看到过。但我记得在第一年，我联系了几位私人心理学家，我想我被列入了等待名单，但我认为我本可以更主动地去跟进那个等待名单，但我没有被联系，现在已经两年了。所以这就像是在思考，如果这对你来说是一个优先事项，确保像我们说的其他不可妥协的事情一样，比如见家人，你知道，保持活跃，和朋友叙旧，治疗对你来说是不可妥协的吗？你
feel like that is an important part of, you know, how you maintain your wellbeing as a trainee. And for some, it could be. And I think for me, I think I would have liked to prioritize that a bit more. But yeah, it is a minefield. When you're juggling everything, you're like, well, should I have also, you know, should I also have therapy? That's kind of another thing to consider. I think when you're under that pressure sometimes of the course, that can slip quite easily and kind of you're focusing on more things which are a priority to you at that time. But yeah, I think it would have been quite, yeah, beneficial to have. Because you just, you just. never know what kind of unconscious processes are kind of going on when you're meeting with someone.
觉得这是你作为实习生维持幸福感的重要组成部分吗？对某些人来说，可能是。我想对我来说，我想我本应该更优先考虑这一点。但，是的，这是一个雷区。当你兼顾一切时，你会想，好吧，我是否也应该，你知道，我也应该接受治疗吗？那是需要考虑的另一件事。我想当你处于课程的那种压力下时，这很容易溜走，你专注于当时对你来说更优先的事情。但，是的，我想如果能有治疗会非常有益。因为你只是，你只是永远不知道当你和某人见面时，什么样的潜意识过程正在发生。
For you, what can personally be triggered. And so maybe having a space to talk through that, because you know, you only have so much time in supervision to really touch on those things. And maybe you're just kind of scratching the surface. So, yeah, would have been quite beneficial. Absolutely. I think this has been such an interesting and helpful conversation about the sort of realities of what it's like to be a trainee psychologist. Is there anything we haven't covered? that you think we should before we finish, Tanya? Yeah, so I think as much as training has been tricky and challenging and there's a lot to juggle at times,
对你来说，什么会触发你的个人情绪。所以也许有一个空间来谈论这些，因为你知道，在督导中你只有有限的时间来真正触及这些问题。也许你只是触及了皮毛。所以，是的，如果能有这样的空间会非常有益。绝对是这样。我认为这是一次非常有趣且有帮助的对话，探讨了作为一名心理学实习生是什么样的现实。Tanya，在我们结束之前，有什么我们还没涵盖到但你认为我们应该谈谈的吗？是的，我认为虽然培训过程很棘手、充满挑战，有时需要兼顾很多事情，
we do as trainees have the opportunity to be in services that we wouldn't, you know, usually be in. I'm in a systemic team now and in a team of all family therapists. So I don't think I would have gotten that opportunity in a qualified position, but it's taught me so much. And so it's really, even with, we're chopping and changing so much, it's giving us insight into some of the things that we would like to consider doing when we qualify or our interests or just knowing what it's like to be
但作为实习生，我们确实有机会进入那些通常无法进入的服务机构。我现在在一个系统式团队中，团队里全是家庭治疗师。我不认为我在获得正式资格后会有这样的机会，但这教会了我很多。所以，即使我们一直在不断变动，它也让我们深入了解了我们在获得资格后想要考虑做的事情、我们的兴趣所在，或者仅仅是了解作为
a supervisor or how you'd like to be supervised, how you wouldn't like to be supervised. So it's all of those little things that kind of come together to inform, you know, the kind of psychologist you'd like to be or the team that you'd like to work in. So I think it, in some ways, to positively reframe that, I think, can be a really helpful experience. to be in different places. Absolutely. And I shared with you a little screenshot that I'd taken in a train station the other day
一名督导是什么感觉，或者你希望如何被督导，不希望如何被督导。所以所有这些小事汇聚在一起，塑造了你想要成为什么样的心理学家，或者你想在什么样的团队中工作。所以我认为，从某种程度上来说，积极地重构这一点，我认为这可以成为一种非常有益的经历，去到不同的地方。绝对是这样。我前几天在火车站拍了一张截图分享给你，
and I'll make sure that this is on screen for anyone on YouTube. But I think it's Bruce Lee. There's a picture of Bruce Lee. And it says, absorb what is useful, discard what is not, add what is uniquely your own.
我会确保在YouTube上为观众展示这张图。我想那是李小龙的名言。有一张李小龙的照片，上面写着：吸收有用的，摒弃无用的，添加属于你自己的独特东西。
And that really resonated with me for thinking about being an aspiring side, and visiting different placements because, yeah, like you might really love aspects of what you, of what they do on your placement in your team. There might be bits that you're like, hell no, as soon as I leave, I'm never doing this again. But there are other bits that you will leave behind that they will be like, oh, actually, you know, they'll still talk about you after you've gone, hopefully in a really good way. And you will have kind of, you know, hopefully enhance that culture and you know your name will live on in the clinical notes and
这对我思考作为一名有抱负的心理学家并访问不同的实习地点产生了很大的共鸣，因为，是的，你可能会非常喜欢你在实习团队中所做工作的某些方面。也可能有一些部分你会觉得，绝对不行，我离开后永远不会再做这些了。但还有其他部分你会留给他们，他们会觉得，哦，实际上，你知道，在你离开后他们还会谈论你，希望是以一种非常好的方式。你可能已经提升了那种文化，你知道你的名字会留在临床记录中，
people will be like oh yeah I remember when Tanya was here and I think that's a really nice a nice thing and I hope that you have had people that have stayed in your phone when you've moved placement and that you you know you'll stay part of each other's lives even if it's just in WhatsApp you know I think that's fine but yeah like this is this is your life yeah don't don't get to live it and don't forget to be authentically you because, yeah, we can't mask our way through, you know, three whole years of our life and then you get to the other end and you're qualified and you're working out who you are. And I guess just to trail our next episode,
人们会说，哦，是的，我记得Tanya在这里的时候，我认为这是一件非常好的事情。我希望当你更换实习地点时，你也能有保持联系的人，即使只是在WhatsApp上，你知道，我认为这很好。但确实，这就是你的生活，不要忘记活出自我，不要忘记保持真实的自己。因为，是的，我们不能在三年的生活中一直戴着面具，等到最后获得了资格，却还在摸索自己是谁。我想，为了预告我们的下一集，
we're going to be recording again another episode on what are the realities of nearing the end of training, are there even any jobs around for this newly developed qualified identity? So thank you so much for your time in this episode, Tanu. It's been really, really reflective. It's been kind of really nice to reconnect some of these ideas and think about some for the first time as well. I really have welcomed your viewpoint and helping us have this conversation that we haven't really had so far on the podcast. So thank you. Thank you, Marianne. Yeah, it's been really lovely to chat with you today. And I think we've, yeah, pulled on some really helpful topics. And it's, yeah, even just your advice, it's been really
我们将再次录制一集，探讨接近培训尾声的现实是什么样的，对于这个新形成的合格身份，真的有工作机会吗？所以非常感谢你在这集节目中付出的时间，Tanya。这真的非常有反思意义。重新连接这些想法，并第一次思考其中的一些问题，感觉真的很棒。我非常欢迎你的观点，并帮助我们进行了这次在播客中尚未真正深入探讨的对话。所以谢谢你。谢谢你，Marianne。是的，今天和你聊天真的很愉快。我认为我们探讨了一些非常有帮助的话题。而且，甚至只是你的建议，对于
helpful to think about just in this next year as I'm coming towards qualifying. Perfect. Thank you. And yeah, do look out for our next episode, which is coming, I think next week, actually. So thank you again, Tanya. Thank you so much to Tanya for her time. Has this, you know, made you feel like you've got more of an idea of what it's like. Does it make you feel validated if you're already on training or indeed have been through training? Is it making you rethink what your options were? I hope not, but I hope that it's opening up your eyes to have full informed consent, right? Because, you know, it is three years of your life. It isn't a small chunk of time. And, you know, your work-life balance really does matter. I'd love to know what this has evoked.
思考我明年即将获得资格的过程也非常有帮助。太完美了。谢谢。是的，请关注我们的下一集，我想实际上就在下周。所以再次感谢Tanya。非常感谢Tanya抽出时间。这是否让你觉得对现状有了更多的了解？如果你已经在接受培训或者确实经历过培训，这是否让你感到被认可？这是否让你重新思考你的选择？我希望没有，但我希望这能让你大开眼界，从而获得充分的知情同意，对吧？因为，你知道，这是你三年的生活。这不是一小段时间。而且，你知道，你的工作与生活平衡确实很重要。我很想知道这引发了你什么样的思考。
for you. Please do drop in the comments either on YouTube or drop a question or a comment on Spotify. You can rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts and if this has wet your appetite for learning more about the realities of being a psychologist, then please do check out the aspiring psychologist collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I was recently reminded that in the Clinical Psychologist Collective, there are actually over 600 years. of cumulative experience from people that are either qualified psychs or trainee psychs. That is a lot of wisdom. If you love these kinds of conversations, then I think you're really, really like the aspiring psychologist membership too. You can
请在YouTube的评论区留言，或者在Spotify上提出问题或发表评论。你可以在Apple Podcasts上为节目评分和评论。如果这激发了你了解更多关于成为心理学家现实的兴趣，那么请务必查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书和《临床心理学家集体》一书。我最近被提醒，在《临床心理学家集体》中，实际上有超过600年的累积经验，来自那些已经获得资格的心理学家或实习心理学家。那是非常多的智慧。如果你喜欢这类对话，那么我想你也会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。你可以
join from just £30 a month with no minimum term by going to my website. And if you'd like to help support me and show me that you're one of my biggest fans, you can absolutely do that by joining us in the paid community, which is on YouTube, where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and Apple, where I'm an aspiring psychologist podcast. You might consider that even if you're qualified or if you're just really invested in helping support people into this profession. With this podcast, that's your side, you're on your way to being qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Tren. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过访问我的网站加入，每月仅需30英镑，没有最低期限要求。如果你想支持我并向我展示你是我的忠实粉丝，你绝对可以通过加入我们的付费社区来做到这一点，该社区位于YouTube（我是Marianne Trent博士）和Apple（我是有抱负的心理学家播客）。即使你已经获得资格，或者你只是非常热衷于支持人们进入这个行业，你也可以考虑这一点。通过这个播客，这就是你的方向，你正在通往获得资格的路上。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。